Hi everyone! I'm Brian Krueger with CollegeGrad.com and this is the Job Search Minute.
Passion is the most important aspect of interviewing.
Passion is how you can differentiate yourself.
So how do you differentiate yourself when your competition is also passionate in their interviews?
Simple, through your passionate examples.
Passion is not just about how passionate you are in the interview.
The real differentiator is your passion in your work.
And it shows by your examples.
Think about the times when you were truly firing on all cylinders.
When you saved the day, when you delivered against all odds, that's true passion.
And that's a truly passionate work example.
So, think about those passionate examples in advance of your interview.
That is how you will differentiate your passion and set you apart from the crowd.
This has been the Job Search Minute.
For more career information, please visit CollegeGrad.com.